can you be canceled for your dreams
would you rather usher a racist word
asleep or [ __ ] yourself i'd rather [ __ ]
myself
i will poop myself on stream for a
hundred thousand
trash taste [ __ ] special let's go
what's up tomato town welcome back to
another episode of trash taste podcast
there's no one in tomato town i hope
this is talking to nobody joey you talk
to nobody it's
real awkward if this meme is dead this
comes out
no we'll bring it back knowing how fast
memes are [ __ ] recycled
i will be singing chug jug till the end
of the year
i'll put money on it by this time next
month
everyone will be like what is a chug jug
anyway i'm your host for this week joey
with the boys connor and god
and uh we will not be talking about
fortnite memes today
you know me i'm a pro fortnight gamer
honestly this is like literally the meme
of like you know the three
children sitting on the couch what's
your favorite fortnite name what's the
title of that video
what is your favorite fortnight what's
the title of that video again
the uh what is it what it is it's like
it's something about fortnite right
yeah of course i don't remember i mean i
mean you know when you see like a meme
picture
and you just have no idea what the
original context of that picture is
yeah like there's so many pictures that
i recognize and i have no idea one that
i want to know is like what's the
context of that picture of like you know
the dudes sitting next to like the three
pictures of like the people having a
podcast
i wouldn't know the context because we
see that all the time when i saw we're
in it
but anyway i was always talking about
this yeah yeah we're not going to be
talking about that i'm not going to be
talking we're going to be talking today
about uh youtube stuff i i guess
twitter stuff and twitter stuff just
well i think there's been a few recent
interesting things that have happened
but i think as we all recorded we are
yeah we're recording i think
we're like this is because we we're
having a bit of a two-week break of
recordings here this is
going to be like six weeks from when we
yeah
this will be all news by the time you
guys are seeing it yeah yeah
but um yeah so as of us recording this i
think
was it two days ago uh youtube the the
official twitter account on youtube uh
announced a an interesting update
they are testing to see whether they
should get just get rid while testing
which when youtube starts to test
something 90 of the time it goes through
yeah so they are testing to see if it's
worth getting rid
of the dislike button wait not getting
rid of it but getting rid of getting rid
of how many dislikes
i've publicly seen on a video
essentially yeah yeah i hope they
it's gonna be real awkward if they
revert it by the time this comes out
i mean i just hope i mean i mean even if
they revert it i i do want them
to i i i will sell on the record now
that i think it's a [ __ ] stupid idea
oh
so just in recent memory what's the only
things i can recall that youtube
backpedaled on was the verification
thing where
verification thing yeah a year and a
half ago or two years ago they were like
um
no one's verified anymore and that's
right only select channels can be
verified
i think it's like only music channels
right well yeah but it was like there
was only
like like the i people with like 10
million subscribers weren't
like eligible or something and it was
like well who the [ __ ] can be verified
um there was that and then there was the
youtube heroes which is the
information oh my god oh my [ __ ] god
i've completely forgotten about that
that was something like last year wasn't
it
that was like four years what was
youtube heroes again
especially where they were gonna like
let people be like moderators
in a way oh yeah i think it was their
answer to like twitch
calling it heroes is like there are
heroes of free
well i mean as the heroes of anime um
you know
yeah but there's just been i don't know
i feel especially with like these
we were talking about it before this
podcast started but i feel that when
youtube
suggests a change or an implementation
to this system it's not so much
a suggestion it's more like hey so no
one asked for this
and uh we're going to tell you right
before it starts happening but this is
what's happening if you disagree with it
lol sorry they also tested one time as
well like just getting rid of people's
thumbnails like that was the thing
remember that where they were just like
no no no no it was like the animated
thumbnail right right it was like
where the previews i mean nowadays on
youtube i think where it's like
if you hover over a video thumbnail then
it plays like a preview
yeah yeah but before yeah i remember
this they were going to get rid of the
idea of thumbnails and just replace it
with the previews of thumbnails
i don't know if that was the intention
that could be wrong but i remember there
was a period where i would log on
youtube
and everything was moving everything
was moving or there was just no
thumbnails for anything and then
i found out later it was because the
this youtube test that they were doing
on like 0.1 percent it just looked like
it just like looked like you know those
newspapers from harry potter yeah
everything is just moving it's it's just
annoying because every it seems like to
me
as a content creator every time youtube
takes one step forward they just take
two steps back
like what was really sus about that
twitter post for me was they were just
like
guys we hear you we hear the creator
feedback we know you asked for this
we are removing the dislike button and
then every creator comes up and went and
was like
yo did you guys answer this because i
didn't ask for this who's feedback
well because anyone who's making any
content that is like
reasonable like anyone who's like
literally trying to make good stuff
probably isn't afraid of the dislike but
yeah because you know personally you
know i mean
might change by this point i've never
had a video that has ever been like
you know less than 90 uh more um yeah
less than 90 likes
yeah i mean i i feel like if it is less
than 90 likes
even like either you [ __ ] up or you
got or got recommended to an audience
way outside of your usual audience which
is
uh which is what i notice but yeah i i
feel like the dislike button
and like the dislike bar at least i
think it's a really useful resource
yeah and i and i saw because i i
retweeted it with the
uh the fallout everyone disliked this
picture yeah um but
yeah i i was reading through the replies
of that tweet and there were a lot of
really like
interesting points being made being like
you know one of the biggest points i saw
from a lot of big creators was that
well if we get rid of the dislike bar
then how are people going to judge
whether the video is like a spam a scam
or you know something is like just
you know you don't want to waste your
time on a 10 minute video yeah i i think
i think the first thing
i think the first thing that came to
mind was for me was tutorial videos
yeah yeah yeah that was the the first
thing because there are so many useless
[ __ ] tutorial videos
and you know immediately when some when
you click on something and the dislike
bar is like it's a 50 50 ratio you're
just like all right
immediately close immediately close down
go to the next one like back in the day
you know maybe
you know maybe you wanted a cert you
know if you wanted some software that
you probably should have been paying for
you know i remember that you know the
way that you would judge if it was a
safe way to get it was like
all right this video is lots of comments
lots of likes yeah yeah yeah i think
this is safe you click on another video
it's like get this software for free and
it's like
yeah like 80 dislikes you're like
probably not gonna download that get it
from this will definitely not hack your
computer.com yeah
for me it's it's you know sometimes
[ __ ] windows or some software gets
this random error and you're just
you start googling it and and for some
reason for me i found that
youtube tutorial videos has been more
useful than just googling it and going
into like specific
microsoft forums which is just like from
like six years ago
like and you look at it it's like posted
in 2012 no reply yes it's like cool
thanks
and it's it's no replies or you get
about like try these 10 million
fixes and one of these will possibly
work but then like
let me just go on tangible yeah there's
[ __ ] [ __ ] as well because
sometimes they'll have
like you know when you have like a
problem that's like very minor and
they'll be like yeah try uninstalling
your ram and gpu and putting it back and
i'm not gonna [ __ ] do that like at
that point i'm giving up yeah i'm
throwing in the trash
yeah but like i i feel that's like the
way youtube tutorials work
is that you know you search up this
error code and i put it on youtube
and like there's going to be one video
that's got a positive like to dislike
ratio and 90
of the time that's the fix i'm looking
for yeah because every other video
is just like 50 50 percent yeah and i
feel like to me that's that's like
legitimately the first thing that came
to mind
yeah about removing dislikes it's
frustrating as well because i think
there have been
changes that youtube has made that like
because i mean i think whenever youtube
makes any change they get [ __ ] like even
if it's a good chance oh yeah of course
yeah um
you know and i think they have made some
changes where everyone was [ __ ] on
it and it started and literally a week
later no one gives a [ __ ]
yeah right like people like okay i
understand why they did this
and it was quite frustrating to get used
to but when they moved the comments
to like the comments used to be when you
would be on a youtube video like this
one right now you could just scroll in
the comments would be right there at the
bottom
right uh but then they moved it so that
you had to just drop down
and it was right there which at first i
absolutely hate it i thought why would
you do this and then now i'm like
this makes way more sense yeah now that
i've gotten used to it it's streamlined
everything if i want to read the
comments i'll
i'll if i want to just you know i don't
have to scroll through all these [ __ ]
videos you know
i mean i mean if we're going you know
all the way back to the like og times
right like i remember there was a
massive uproar when
youtube changed the you know from the
five-star rating that was dog [ __ ]
anyway
[Music]
i mean i understand
but like i remember back in the day
people were like no i'm so used to like
raiding five stars now yeah
youtubers were like well how am i gonna
end off the video i used to be able to
say rate five stars but now i gotta like
ask people to like like smash the like
button that's the like button
i i do think that when they do these
changes as well
like they must have some data on their
end yeah that says this is a good idea
yeah right well yeah it's not completely
baseless i'm sure right which is why
like i wish that they would be like
listen about it this is our idea right
yeah
we're thinking not be like listen we're
you
i [ __ ] hate that don't [ __ ]
pretend like you're doing
me a solid yeah you [ __ ] do anything
don't pretend like you give a [ __ ]
about the people who use your website
thanks corporation my best friend
you want to do me a solid reply to me
when i have a [ __ ] problem
don't [ __ ] tell me that you're
removing dislikes and then he wasn't
[ __ ] doing it anyway and i'm pretty
sure everyone knows they're doing it
because of this because like you know a
bunch of really big names got into
controversy yeah and dislikes play a
really pivotal part
right like because you know i think in
youtube
we have this way where we have like kind
of decided that
a youtube or an apology if you will its
success is based on
like to dislike yeah yeah right so i
think that youtube is trying to get rid
of that while we judge your videos
you know quality well i kind of like
that because i mean obviously you know i
wouldn't be saying this if i was on the
receiving end
but as someone who's seeing you know oh
i like it i think apologies
it's also cool as well because i a lot
of the times use that as a gauge
to figure out like the general idea of
what the community thinks about this
particular
this particular because sometimes you
know when these apology videos come out
and i'm like
you know it's a good apology i look at
the video and there's like you know 20
000 likes to a hundred thousand dislikes
yeah i'm like whoa why does everyone
like
what's that yeah like what if i think
well i don't know i'm missing something
exactly exactly it like it kind of re i
guess it like re-justifies like oh
do i really fully understand the whole
context of this video because
yeah i might think this is a good
apology video but a hundred thousand
other people disagree
so it's kind of like oh okay well then
maybe i should walk into it more but
also there's just something cathartic
about having the dislike button there
you know this
it just doesn't feel right if you're
just smashing a button and it just
doesn't really mean anything
it's like it's like going on onto a
video right
and just seeing the comments turned off
nothing makes me more like angry
than going on not even wanting to
comment on it just wanting to see what
other people think right
yeah and just being remove that
privilege exactly and i just feel like
as well
this is just gonna lead to more shitty
comments
because if you take away one avenue as
you know you know we we all saw with uh
oh what is it like twitter right it's
just rationing now that's that's that's
like the new thing
did twitter ever have a dislike button i
don't think it did no no they never had
it
yeah no but oh they felt they changed
they took um
oh i feel like i feel like rationing is
a recent thing though
rationing is a recent thing yeah yeah
why do rationing start happening
i think it's because we want to explain
what ratioing is like i've talked to
several people and they've not known
what ratio is well ratioing
oh i mean on twitter yeah it's just
basically like where if if
a tweet is so bad right you'll know it's
an awful tweet
when there'll be like more replies than
likes and that's that's called rating
because you're
like the ratio is so much higher to call
it more of a reply to the original tweet
has more likes than the yeah
exactly exactly it's like both either
ways right yeah i feel like
you know if there's likes on the video
people are just going to start rating in
the comments
oh yes they're just going to like up the
one talking [ __ ] yeah yeah but but on
youtube you can delete the comments as
well right
exactly i i don't know it just seems
like a stupid idea i don't know
that's the thing right yeah that's the
thing right and and i think that's why
it's such a big problem for people
because i think a lot of youtubers
realize that
because creators can and have the space
to delete comments if they want to and
delete like hateful
you know hurtful negatives should be
able to which you should be able to
don't get me wrong
yeah but you know you can't get rid of a
dislike
right and for a lot of people if they go
onto a youtube video and they realize
oh this person who uploaded this video
is getting rid of negative comments
well then the only other way i can
express how i feel about this video
is to hit the dislike button yeah and
another thing is like
the way they framed it like they were
doing a solid for the creator
where the creator they they literally
said the creator can still see the dis
how many dislikes this video has right
so it doesn't help the creator at all
because they're the only ones
who can still see it right i i felt the
exact same way
when instagram got rid of publicly
showing how many likes a post has and
yet the creator can still see how many
likes the post has
i'm just like what's the difference at
that point like you're still putting
this like pressure on
the person i'd actually argue i think it
was a good thing i think it was a good
thing
yeah i think so because i think
instagram was like
highly competitively toxic with likes
and i guess maybe i didn't think that
way because i'm not part of it yeah
i'm i'm not a like if you follow me on
instagram i'm sorry that sir
it's just like zero content and zero
updates that's all it's a
dead account really says a lot when out
of the three of us i'm the most active
instagram and yet i post like once a
month
i just like don't like the platform that
much and i think it used to be like the
likes was definitely a thing that i
didn't really
like at all to me that was like because
it because it really felt like people
were just like farming and just like
[ __ ]
wait it really bred this toxic
kind of environment where people were it
was literally like a cloud chasing kind
of platform
well that question then would you guys
if twitter for example
implements the same things instagram did
would you be okay with it
i would actually really i don't know i
feel like twitter is different
yeah right i don't i wouldn't want it on
twitter wait okay before we get into
that though yeah yeah
i i have this like i don't know if this
is like tinfoil hat a part of me just
thinks is youtube just trying to shift
all the drama
onto like twitter like you can't you
because you like now right let's say
you know you can't you can't dislike
something publicly let's say the
comments are filtered
yeah i i wonder is youtube just being
like go to twitter go and argue on
twitter don't [ __ ] i didn't think
about that
but uh that's uh now it's you know with
the dislikes gone
what is there to do other than comment
and you know a lot of the time with
these videos
people just gonna turn off comments
right [ __ ] [ __ ] great just even
more toxicity
i do i do wonder because you know if you
know even if it's a youtube creative all
the shit's going down on twitter
i wonder if youtube can be like oh i
mean i i i feel like that's not going to
happen because
there are such there's been such an
increase in like commentary and drama
channels now
that the conversation is still going to
stay on youtube
it's just a lot of people maybe can only
publicly comment on about it
also also if anything it does really
seem like
to on at first glance it does seem like
everyone who is following something on
youtube
also uses twitter but that is really not
the case like i
i very quickly found out that yes even
though i might have a massive following
on twitter
compared to like the people who use
youtube it's really not
a lot it's not even the majority of
people yeah like
i remember like there was one time where
like i posted something on my twitter
and then i talked about it on my youtube
and i got a lot of people being like
well i don't use twitter yeah
but in the back of my head i was like oh
yeah there are some people who don't use
twitter
well i mean i think it's gotten to the
point now where i've kind of had this
realization where
every platform is kind of like in its
own it's most of the time it's in its
own bubble
right you can be really really popular
on one platform and then open an account
on
another platform and just have like
really like zero followers i mean
there's so many like you know youtubers
who have a million plus subs on their
youtube but then when you go onto their
twitter they have you know less than
fifty thousand followers like
the content right that's like kind of
how it you know yeah right but like also
like i can't imagine how many [ __ ]
tick tockers i just don't know about
just because i'm not on the platform
oh yeah yeah and the thing is like they
can open a twitter account because to me
like
the the way i see twitter now is just
like [ __ ] influence of facebook
it literally is that's basically what
it's like for me now and
like sometimes i hear about a tick tock
who has like [ __ ] millions and
millions of followers on tick tock opens
to twitter and it's like
like you know less followers than us
even though they have like more
followers on their own platform
right in youtube terms if they had that
many subscribers
on like youtube then there would be
massive creators
not all followers subscribers are
created equal though right yeah yeah
that's true that's true
like it it also really depends on how
much you
focus and post on that platform yeah
that's true like
and how much you're known by your
audience to use that platform yeah yeah
exactly
yeah man i i wondered because i i'm
thinking like
you know as content creators you know
if you're somebody who say does not give
a [ __ ]
about anything and you're like i don't
care people say about me i feel like the
only
really tool that like an audience or a
platform has
to kind of um what's the word police
or give feedback is like public shaming
almost
i feel like getting rid of the dislike
is a part of like you know
taking away from that because i feel
like as content creations uh
content creation creators sorry my gosh
you know the only real tool
other than like youtube deleting your
channel is like you know
and it sounds bad because it sounds
really [ __ ] terrifying is it public
shaming but that's like the only real
tool that is there to like stop you from
doing shitty stuff yeah yeah most of the
time
for a lot of people yeah yeah who are
questionable
because i don't think i don't think
removing the dislike button is not going
to get rid of toxicity yeah you know
it's it's not it's like it's just going
to get people to figure out
other creative ways no it's excuse that
toxic exactly right
all that's going to happen is it's going
to shift into another form
and i feel like to me i removing the
dislike button is just
so weird to me because it's just
censorship i don't think it's that i
don't think it's censorship
i mean i feel it's like a form of it
right because again like
you know if there's again like a video
where it's
an apology video or something
controversial and you turn off the
comments and the dislikes aren't
well then how else are you supposed to
say anything about it i feel like the
term censorship gets thrown
around a lot nowadays you know i feel
like this is
pushing the definition of what
censorship is but what it is
is that it's removing a way for us to
express
ourselves and um i've i
i wonder if it's a similar case to when
um
you know when the whole kids the kids on
youtube thing
where were like all doing like
gymnastics or something people
commenting gross things
and then youtube's trump's response was
well we'll just turn off all the
comments for kids videos
and then you just like well there's no
more pedophiles on youtube now they're
all gone
if you can't see them then they're not
there right where are they there's no
negativity on youtube there's no
dislikes what do you mean
you know this is it almost feels like
that youtube's like if you just remove
the option to show it publicly to anyone
it doesn't exist it's just the whole
like you know evil there's [ __ ] tons
of videos of kids doing
probably inappropriate things on youtube
still like that [ __ ] creeps are
probably still watching them right
yeah yeah but now it's harder to [ __ ]
find these videos and report them
because like you know
how the [ __ ] are you supposed to when
you know there's not like a bunch of
creepy dudes in the comments
unless you like actively go out and
search for those videos but who the [ __ ]
is wasting their time doing that right
oh yeah i mean like normal people who
are trying to get rid of those right
it's like yeah
i mean there's so many circles and so
many like rabbit holes that
i'm sure people can fall down on youtube
that it's just like that we're just not
aware of
you know like it's because that just
shows how big youtube is as a platform
and
how like i mean i i feel for youtube
because when you have a platform this
big
no matter what you do there's going to
be something wrong with your platform
right
yeah 100 yeah but i i feel like what
they're doing with the dislike button is
it's going in the wrong direction just
because just because
a problem exists like removing your
ability to express it or removing your
ability to see that problem doesn't get
rid of the problem it just shifts it to
somewhere else
and yeah i i don't know i i don't know
what they were thinking i
don't know i feel it's not even about
like shifting it as well it's like it's
not only shifting it but i feel
more times than not it also propels it
into something like a lot more toxic and
a lot more just out of control
i think it i think it would breed more
toxicity yeah because that just means
people have to find
another way it just means that like the
people who are shouting
the toxicity now just have to shout it
even louder yeah yeah
like well i need people to see what i
have a problem with
yeah because if like part of the
cathars catharsism i don't know if
that's a word of like seeing a shitty
video
is just knowing that you're not the only
one who agrees that this is a shitty
video right exactly
right and you know there's there's you
know there it is it is good when you see
like this bad video this bad apology
and you know every you can see that one
the first thing you see
is the dislike button and the dislike
bar like my god
it was great seeing like youtube rewind
and just seeing that everyone
collectively agreed that it was just a
train wreck right
sorry youtube but it was i love how a
lot of the comments as well were like oh
man youtube was just salty that they got
there they got ratio
like actually i don't think i don't
think that was a reason on record but it
was funny it was a good meal
like this is the official reason
corporates at youtube are like
[ __ ] i can't believe people would hate
our products susan's just like i'm never
gonna forgive them like
i cannot believe it after all these
years she's just been planning
this for years waiting for like the
right person to be cancelled to be like
okay now it's the time to give an excuse
to implement it
i wonder if they were like there was
just a youtube meeting they're like guys
everyone
everyone's hating on cancer culture
right now let's be the ones to end
cancer culture let's remove the dislike
button
and they're like oh my god you're a
genius they're going to love all
youtubers are going to love this
who would have thought it was that easy
they can't be cancelled anymore there's
no dislikes
why why is everyone hating this what is
happening i thought we were doing a good
thing i thought you guys hated cancer
removing negativity what that's what it
feels like
yeah it really is cause like like before
this i would say that
actually i think youtube was in a pretty
healthy stage yeah twitter was
[ __ ] but youtube was good like yeah
youtube was good like
twitter was like toxic and obviously
felt a bit vile sometimes but youtube
just felt like just a dislike and that
was it
it was just it was a nice balance it
wasn't like a little finger
[ __ ] you yeah like [ __ ] you okay i'll
get on with my day now
you know and like i think they have done
a lot of positive changes
um i do like the changes they did to the
copyright system it's not perfect
but it's better than it was before i
like the fact that you have to like
specifically put a timestamp of
what part is part of your videos being
copyrighted yeah and as a creator you
can still remove that
you know part that's being copyright
strikes and have no effect on your
channel i think that's
like the best balance that we could have
hoped for and when you appeal for it it
like goes
the the money you make from that video
now goes into this limbo state where it
doesn't go to the creator and it doesn't
go to the supposed copyright holders
yeah that was that was a good challenge
[ __ ] fantastic we've been wanting
that for years yeah and youtube was like
we've heard your feedback to be fair
that probably should have happened
in the beginning yes i mean it should
have happened in the in the beginning
but what i'm saying is if
they eventually did it yeah they
eventually did it and it felt like this
changed the changes they're making now
is just it's just unnecessary because
nobody asks for this and i think right
now
before this as a content creator i was
pretty happy with youtube as a platform
you know
you knew what you knew what you could
get away with you knew what you couldn't
get away with
you know if i i feel like right now if
if a video if one of your video gets
demonetized aside from aside from trash
taste videos because
yeah i don't know why half the videos
they got to monetize
yeah monetize most of the time if i
upload something and it's a 10 to 15
minutes
i know which videos are more high risk
to get demonetized and i know most of
the time
it's kind of on meat for making that
video subject um
and then you have trash taste where for
some reason some of our podcast episodes
just get demonetized
and we hit and and it's just like we hit
we hit the appeal button and i
guarantee the person who's like
reviewing the content
did not watch the entire time like oh
[ __ ] it's two hours long
yeah jim you're going to watch the whole
thing no [ __ ] it or just leave yellow
then
what's weird about the trash taste
episodes is that i think on record we
have about like maybe
five or six of the episodes now that are
still demonetized but it's five or six
episodes that
shouldn't have been demonetized yeah
like we look at it we look back at and
we're like
i don't know what part of this video
flagged what but
we have like a bunch of other videos and
episodes where it's like
these are the ones if anything that
should have been demonetized yeah yeah
but they're not for some reason like the
company episode that got demonetized
and yet the hentai episode is still
monetized
oh sorry the the fancy font episode
one is still monetized yeah the greek
the greek letter
anyway oh my gosh yeah i don't know it's
just
i don't know the one time like one day i
think to myself
okay i figured out what exactly it is
that youtube does not like
yeah about whatever video it is that
flags the demonetization system and then
the next day i'm like
never mind i don't i don't know what you
want because another thing i've noticed
about youtube recently
is in in a positive light man when did
youtube comments
get really good i don't is that just me
what do you mean
what do you mean good in the comment the
comment section right now like you click
on a random meme video and the comments
are always golden and i
it didn't used to be that way because it
used to be like this one overused joke
in every comment section but
no one connor yeah yeah yeah yeah like
the no one they were all [ __ ] copy
pastors yeah yeah
but not but not i don't know if it's
just me but i think like yeah pretty
funny
yeah like like half of my enjoyment when
clicking on a random video just going to
the comment section it's weird because
i feel like the whole like you know
commenting
on in a meme format in a meme video yeah
it's just like
i don't know people are just thinking to
themselves okay in order for me to stand
out in this absolute
cesspool of comments on this one video
yeah i actually need to be
surprised creative about it otherwise
i'm just going to get
swept in with all of these other like
meh so now people
now there's like this weird pressure to
be like if i'm going to comment on this
meme video
i'm going to make a [ __ ] bang a joke
otherwise
no one's gonna like it and it's just
gonna get buried and then you haven't
commented
in the first hour so you're not gonna be
in the top comments anyway yeah exactly
this episode is sponsored by expressvpn
i know that none of you watch porn right
no
of course you but just in case you have
any friends that do
you'll want to pay attention to this
with everything going on in the world
governments have increased their
surveillance they're using your devices
to track your location movements and in
many countries your internet activity
the score stand you don't want to be
literally caught with your pants down do
you and one of the best ways to keep
your online browsing interview private
is by using expressvpn when you use
expressvpn your internet connection is
rerouted through a secure encrypted
server so you can surf the web
anonymously without anyone looking over
your shoulder i know you're probably
thinking that all you have to do is use
incognito mode and no one can see that
you've watched every last hentai video
on pornhub wait that's that's not how it
works
you're wrong again joey no even when
you're using incognito mode your
internet provider like comcast or at t
can see every single website you visit
and if you live on campus or you shared
wi-fi your network admin can
too it's kind of scary that's why i use
expressvpn whenever i go online and i
recommend
all of you do the same without
expressvpn you're giving people a free
license to peek over your shoulder
and frankly see all the freaky [ __ ]
you're looking at i will not stand for
that and that's why i will get
expressvpn so protect your privacy today
and get three months of expressvpn for
free
visit expressvpn.com trash taste that's
expre
trash taste for free three months on a
one-year package it's an insane deal so
what are you waiting for go and visit
expressvpn.com that's the episode so i'm
curious as
as content creators and youtubers um who
have not given their feedback
influencers as influencers who have not
actually given their feedback to youtube
is there anything you would like to say
to youtube to
improve the platform is there any actual
feedback
you would like to give to youtube apart
from and and hopefully
they'll actually hear us uh that's a
good question
i don't know yeah because like for me i
like i don't know there's there's
another system that's just been
recently implemented and it's the
checking system uh
yeah like i i uploaded a video recently
and yeah so so for those of you who
don't know
um when when you upload a video uh
youtube usually like some pre-checks to
make sure it was like content friendly
and contact
contents monetizable now those checks
for for absolutely no reason
just take an hour plus yes
yeah i feel i don't know if it's because
it's like this new system is in beta or
whatever but
but i heard nothing about this they
weren't transparent about that at all
yeah yeah yeah
i remember like the first time it
happened on one of my videos i was like
oh no am i in trouble yeah what's going
on why are they like
diagnosing yeah why are they like
[ __ ] like enhance enhance this video
to be like we gotta find at least one
frame where we could [ __ ]
sick this guy i don't know i don't know
who the [ __ ] is in charge of pr but like
why does it always feel that when they
like tell us something
finally they tell us something it's like
just the dumbest [ __ ]
like we didn't need to know that the
dislikes are being removed
yeah how about you just reply to my
emails when i'm like having a problem
like yeah
i think that's just the one thing that
has consistently been an issue that i
think everyone talks about which is like
communication
and the fact that when you have an issue
that could be very simple just becomes
ten times more difficult because
you're just like [ __ ] you i'm not gonna
talk to you yeah and then it's like well
you know it's not like you're you're not
making a decent money for youtube you
know yeah
that's your living it feels like well
you know well that's the thing right
like and that's part that's the part
where i can't exactly be like
wow youtube i can't believe you ignore
us like that because i mean [ __ ] like
how many channels are there now that
have over a million subs right
yeah already that's like thousands and
thousands and there there's just there's
probably
all of those youtubers probably have at
least one period in their life where
they're like i need you to reply to me
so yeah
i i feel like how how often do you need
to email youtube for help
like once a year at most yeah like maybe
once or twice so then like
at that level right let's say if there
is like some kind of mythical barrier
it's like a million subs
you get to have someone that doesn't
seem too unreasonable to me
but also i feel like it's something that
youtube just doesn't want to do either i
don't want to [ __ ] with that
and and again like you know that would
be fine if
it was only those like million plus subs
who even have
access to the youtube email right yeah
literally you know you could have a
channel with [ __ ] 10 subs be like um
youtube why did you delete my video
please help right yeah so it's like
because most you know if you if you are
a youtuber right you'll probably follow
an
account called team youtube on twitter
yeah which like youtube customer support
but not on their own [ __ ] platform
yeah but it's a bot yeah
you know you could you might treat them
something that gets like tons of
attention tons of stuff and then
they won't reply to it but they'll be
replying to someone who's like like a
bunch of other people who are like hey i
got locked out of my account they're
like oh well
here's how you can do it it's like [ __ ]
that in order to get youtube's attention
you literally have to ratio them
no you do i mean you have to you have to
spam them it's unfortunate yeah you do
it's like
you just got a ratio youtube's like [ __ ]
you got me all right we'll help you out
like how well can you ratio that's how
quickly
we will reply to your email but also you
know like i've heard
people who have gotten immense amount of
help just because they
you know went to like one youtube event
met a youtube employee and then they'll
pull strings for you
yeah right and and that feels like it's
like being in like [ __ ] prison it's
like well your mate knows the prison
guard so you're not going to get shanked
yeah
yeah how is that fair like i'm stuck in
this system and i have to work with you
yeah i can't [ __ ] do it maybe i don't
want to go to your [ __ ] workshop
youtube have you thought about that
maybe i just want some help
because my video got wronged because the
only time i ever got help from youtube
was um because i got very lucky and
um i had a really good partner manager
who was super super like i think i think
at the time they were new to
youtube and they were super down like
really be in depth and talk with me and
be like hey what do you need what do you
need help with
and they were very nice and helped me
out a lot you know and
i was just sitting there the whole time
i was getting all this help i was like
oh my god like i sent how many [ __ ]
emails did so many other things we shot
so many people all it took was just one
youtube employee
who was nice to me who recommended me to
like the engineering team or whatever
yeah yeah all my problems got fixed
and it's like this is so dumb that this
is what it takes
but i have to be like i have to have a
man on the inside me
you need a double agent it's like you
know and and
they don't work there anymore so i don't
even have the help anymore so now i'm
[ __ ] by
the issues square on right i just got to
like cry on twitter and it's so i hate
doing that i don't want your child
right do you want you know one feature
on youtube i do genuinely want removed
well and i don't know if i'm i would be
the only one here the
your video is this ranked out of 10 of
your previous 10 videos no
i i i like i i understand it does serve
a use
but i don't i don't know
i'm like indifferent to it because it's
like it it depends on how well the video
is really
where it's like what's the point where
it's the point where it's like if i see
a video and it's like
your video got less views from your
frequent viewers
nine out of ten when it's just like [ __ ]
this system but then when it's like
one out of ten and you see those
fireworks you're like damn i'm good
i think we've explained the system about
it before yeah recap real quickly
youtube ranks
your videos and how they're doing
against your other videos the past 10
videos it ranks them one out of ten one
yeah the best 10 being the worst
i actually quite like it as much as i
hate it i like it i think it's good you
know um
i before i remember did you just have
like an estimate in your head of what
was good
views yeah yeah yeah for me it was like
if i get so and so views
in the first 24 hours good view if it's
over that great video yeah with that is
that that you know your average of what
i expect video to get is never static
and that number is always changing and i
think it's good because
i don't know what i should be aiming for
and at least this has kind of helped me
like set expectations and figure out
okay
you know it's it's been a really good
way of figuring out personally all right
if something's number 10 all right let
me
let me go and reevaluate that yeah it
[ __ ] sucks i'm happy about it yeah
and sometimes i genuinely do think it
was a
really [ __ ] good video they got
[ __ ] by one reason or another
um but most of the time i do feel like
it's been really helpful
as much as it makes me want to just like
quit i feel though like
it's kind of a double-edged sword in
that case though because i remember
where
you know when you have like say a really
[ __ ] good streak right of like
one to two months of worth of videos
that are just a banger after banger
after banger that's like all over
perfectly you know you're in the stock
market you're bubbling
you know you know the fall is coming yes
and then you're like i'm i'm expecting
the fall where's the fall
and then you wake up the next morning
and your newest video is like nine out
of ten or even like a ten out of ten
right yeah
and you're like well [ __ ] this is the
end of my trip here's what you do but
then when you look at that video
like in retrospect if you just say screw
it to the other nine videos let me just
look at this video on its own
right and it's actually doing okay it
just feels like the video is like crap
because your other nine videos were just
over performing right yeah you want to
hear a big bane big brain strap
just make a [ __ ] video
just make a [ __ ] video right you
purposely make it 10 out of 10.
that's what i do right every now and
then you know i as much as uh
i i think all my ideas are you know
mostly good
but sometimes i'll make a video and it
comes out [ __ ]
yeah and then i'm like you know what
fine have a 10 out of 10.
put my expectations down release reset
the x-men
i'm like yeah i'm like let's just let's
just [ __ ] let's humble myself for a
moment here let's just upload a [ __ ]
video
i have uploaded videos where i thought
like oh my god what am i doing
yeah and then like i've also had the
opposite happen where i'm like this is a
10 out of 10 video
and i'm like this is god really yeah
unwatchable and it literally got like
one out of ten and i'm like i [ __ ]
hate it here
yeah this video sucked i've had that
before the worst ones are like
damn there's gonna be a banger video
nine out of ten yeah
yeah oh nothing feels worse nothing
feels worse feels worse
like my entire like i do check that in
the morning once the video goes yeah
i see that and i'm just like entire day
ruined yeah just like that i guess what
i think is that
maybe like i do see usefulness in it so
i don't think it should be removed but
i think it should be harder to find
because it's like front and center
it is literally the first thing you see
the first literally the first thing you
see
when you log in right to your account
and you're you're
like youtube's either giving you a clap
or being like son
i expect it better from you what the
[ __ ] is wrong
man i don't know i can't i think it's
all right i think where it is is joke
fine honestly i i i this is how you like
personally perceive it right
i i think it very much takes a
you have to kind of take your emotions
out of it a little bit to really
appreciate it i mean
that sounds so robotic you have to be
like i think you just have to appreciate
the data for what it is like
i mean all it is is neatly packaging
the the truth you're hiding from
yourself in a way that is digestible
within 10 seconds i think you know
that's that's that's the uh
that's the was a healthy advice to be
like yo you you just get over it
just not just stop being sad just don't
be emotional
why are you feeling emotions because
like you know it's just your livelihood
i mean we've talked about before like
how you know a lot of youtubers before
said
they don't care about the views but you
know you do have like as much as you
want to think that you are not
emotionally attached to your content and
the numbers around your content
it you do care at some level you do care
and it's not like i
i think you just have you would have to
be like a heartless robot to
make something you're proud of and not
care about how many people view it
right the way i see it it's like i don't
care if i spill my drink
but i care if i spill my drink and it
wrecks my pc and [ __ ] everything up
right i feel like there's an acceptable
amount of
[ __ ] up that i'm like ah i'll deal
with that right
if i get one ten out of ten all right
well all right you know it happens it
happens something's gotta be ten out of
ten well yeah of course
two ten out of tens in a row all right
okay
you know that happens sometimes you know
yeah yeah three ten out of ten i'm okay
all right well okay what is going on
yeah
that's when i started that's when it
starts to affect me yeah but the first
one i don't really let it affect me i'm
like you know what like
just statistics are just saying that
this is gonna happen eventually like
right no i i completely get that right
like of course eventually you're gonna
have to get
i love math and you know i appreciate it
no i do too don't get me wrong but like
you know
i know i know that eventually this
streak or whatever it is i'm on
is going to eventually run out right
yeah and then and you know even then if
you think about it right the more you're
getting five out of ten six editions
yeah
all you're doing is making it closer and
closer right so if you're getting one
out of tens or ten out of tens every
time you're making a like famine or fee
situation which is fine
but what i'm at right now at least my
past few videos have all been around
like give or take like
minimal percentage away from each other
like the difference between third and
eight for me is nothing
yeah yeah so like at that point i'm like
i don't even feel bad
about any of it ninth or third it's
barely any difference to me
so why is youtube trying to make [ __ ]
feel bad about it stop that no but
because there's there's another factor
that i feel like this doesn't take
like account for and that's like a
long-term performance of a video
because some of my videos some of my
videos that have been a 9 10 out of 10
have gone on to grown to be like some of
my some of my most popular videos
and i feel like it what this what this
system
like really emphasizes is how well video
does short term whereas youtube as you
as as like a content creator has been on
the platform for a very long time
i know that short term performance
doesn't mean a lot
but like no matter what no matter if i
make a video that i'm proud of and i
think it's going to perform well long
term
i still feel [ __ ] about it if it just is
that nine or ten hours
we need one out of your whole channel
uploads
like one out of like 1 000 or whatever
how many uploads you have right
i mean i think that's just going on to
the videos and looking up most popular
yeah but then but then you'll always
feel good because you'll never have like
a lowest one ever again because you'll
never have less views
like youtube come on like whenever
you're feeling bad you're just like let
me just go check out my most viewed
videos of all time you know what i still
got it
because like okay like i don't know if i
was talking about this i don't know how
the views feel about this being like
wow this is such a first world problems
nowadays like jesus christ
they're complaining about this but the
reason the reason like i think about it
a lot is because
before before this i really did not give
a [ __ ] about like i didn't
not not that i didn't give a [ __ ] i
didn't really put as much focus on my
mental health
until i started working in a creative
industry and then i realized
oh [ __ ] my mental health actually
matters when it comes to my work
where before i would just like grind out
my job feel like [ __ ] but it would be
easy right
and then drink the sadness and then
drink the sadness away or just
like [ __ ] wait for the weekend you
live for the weekend you've reset
but now it's like a constant okay i
actually have to care about this thing
otherwise it will literally affect
how well i'm performing at my job i have
no more weekends and i'm constantly home
and i'm not
but like not i'm not saying like you
know if you have bad mental health then
you'll have an easy time doing your job
but it's just
like in a creative job you really see
the effects
of having bad mental health which is why
to me like this
like this a system like this to me is
like you you
you get more l's and you get more than
w's in my opinion
no of course absolutely and it's it's a
system where it's it's like you you get
that one w
like three times out of ten because you
know you're fighting in a system that
you have
absolutely no control over right it's
like you can't control whether a video
gets a ten or a one like
it's just it's just how it is right so
when you do get that one or you do get
that dub it's like
[ __ ] 300 winning against the persian
empire right it's like oh [ __ ]
i mean i wasn't expecting it but [ __ ] me
i'll take it you know
i was pulling through yeah literally you
know there's another feature on
uh the whole rating your videos and how
they perform thing which i i don't
actually quite like because i think it's
just
what the language they use is like [ __ ]
off yeah right it's right this video is
performing
worse than usual yeah
i wish i could just put it in like like
another language like [ __ ] off i don't
want to read this [ __ ]
yeah it's it's like that passive
aggressive note that's left on your
fridge when you're living in university
right
it's like [ __ ] i can i know how
to read a graph yeah i don't need you to
tell me
it's like there's like there's just one
curve that is lower than the other yeah
this curve is lower than the other
that means it's doing worse and i'm like
no [ __ ] it's doing that's typically how
graphs work
it tells you information what i what i
hate is that it starts off with like the
layman's terms of like this is
performing worse than usual and then it
goes on to be like it's performing 40
7 less it's like you didn't you could
have just got rid of that first part you
could have just said it's performing 47
percent yes
and i would have it's the pandering
language that youtube tries to use of
like yeah we care about you
we hear you you know we're here this
isn't an intervention
but it could be yeah so sort of [ __ ] out
it's frustrating how do you guys feel
about the algorithm itself
i don't give a [ __ ] anymore i don't even
know what it is at this point like
you know again it's not yeah when you
grow right you give a [ __ ] you're like
well like write that down anytime
anytime matpat would say anything you're
like [ __ ] write that down yeah whenever
you're going you're like well [ __ ] i
mean i need to be listening to this
otherwise i'm going to be stuck in my
sub count forever but when you get to a
certain point
and you can just kind of make whatever
the hell you want it's just like
i feel like i figured it out and then
some days it's just like nope that's not
how that works yeah i mean i feel like
every creator at least
that has been around for a while and and
i feel like this is probably like a
reason why you do stay around a while is
that you just stop
valuing um like getting crazy sub growth
yeah yeah just being like
i just want to make good [ __ ] that just
maintains what i have like
you know i don't think you need to keep
growing we will keep growing
yeah um but it's not something i really
care about that's my mentality of it's
like at the end of the day
if i see that i have more subs at the
end of the day than i did at the
beginning of the day whether that's one
sub or 10 000 subs it's like well
i'm still here i guess because like i
feel like i feel like as a youtuber
it's the hard part is getting to around
like 100k to 500k subscribers but i feel
like like
you know because lucky can play such a
big part yeah in in
in that and like getting your videos on
the algorithm itself but i feel like
once you get to
around that size it like it becomes more
predictable than people give you credit
for yeah you know because
at that point it becomes more like a
game right where you know
you know what's going to perform well
you know you you you kind of know what's
going to perform well
and sometimes you get this lucky hit
where you're just like i don't know why
this video is doing so well but
most of the time if you get to uh pass
100k you can
kind of predict how what you need to do
to grow yeah if you understand the
system
yeah you understand the platform this
episode is sponsored by mac welder
gamers
this year spring is gonna hit a little
different
because we're all starting to finally
get outside and see friends again no
matter where your adventures take you
bring the comfort and style of mac
weldon along for the ride
trust me your closet is going to thank
you whether it's their hoodies polos
teas or active shorts everything in the
mac walden collection mixes and matches
seamlessly to fit in with any other
trendy products you have i'm actually
wearing the mac world and underwear
right now
socks shirts hoodies underwear polos or
active shorts mac weldon promises
comfort and a consistent fit
and with the world and blue program a
totally free loyalty program
level one gets you free shipping for
life and once you reach level two by
spending two hundred dollars you get
twenty percent off
every order for the next year and don't
forget about the mac weldon guarantee
mac welder wants you to be comfortable
so if you don't like your first pair of
underwear you can keep them and i'll
still refund you
no questions asked so what are you
waiting for for 20
off your first order visit macweldon.com
trash taste and
enter promo code trash taste that's
macweldon.com
trash taste promo code trash taste for
20
off mac weldon reinventing men's basics
back to the episode i feel like it's
almost like
you know to get to the million you know
you have to go through like the proving
grounds of sorts right
like to get to that size you have to
consistently prove to youtube
that you can make content that is
engaging to people and then i feel like
you can just kind of be like all right
well
you know i feel like it feels like less
effort because you just know what you're
doing
yeah so you feel like i put less thought
into things so i'm like well i you know
i know that won't work inherently like
just by looking at stuff i'm like that's
about thumbnail that's a bad title you
know yeah yeah
um and then you can just kind of like
not take it easy but you can focus more
on just
having a healthy work schedule right
yeah i mean because i mean we've said
this before 100 times and i'm sure
everyone can figure out you know when
you first start out it's
brutal the hours you put in oh yeah of
course for nothing but i also like
you know like two dollars if you're
lucky but i also like i remember you
know back in the day when i was still
growing i
never once thought to myself that's a
good title or that's a bad title that's
a good that's a bad thing i just tried
to explain the video
yeah and then i was like wait that's
that's i was just like
here is image of game with number in the
corner yeah episode seven
yeah i'd be like i'd be like the
sebastian call where the girl gets
excited
and it was like well that's not that's
not a good time i started changing it up
yeah but past you was like well i mean
now people know what this video is right
yeah yeah i i feel like the platform has
changed a lot since
we started growing you could get away
with doing the parts before yeah
you can't do video parts now unless you
have like a massive series that people
are really waiting right yeah yeah yeah
we say parts of our [ __ ] trash taste
is part yeah we've literally put numbers
on each of
us that's just for ease isn't it keep
track of it yeah i mean it's it's kind
of like i mean
it's past but you can enjoy each part i
mean it's i don't even call it a part
it's an episode number right
and you can enjoy each episode by itself
and then there are also people who are
just like are like totally ingrained in
like the trash taste lore
whatever the [ __ ] that is like i go into
our subreddit sometimes and i'm just
like
man the amount the amount of layers that
new
like viewers would have to understand
just to get this one meme is [ __ ]
ridiculous we literally have
a chronological order and like a [ __ ]
like law order
no it's it's watching order and
chronicles because like the trash tastes
lore
like watching our subreddit goes beyond
just our channel now
and just it's just like everyone we've
ever interacted with it's now part of
the trash taste lore
it's hilarious i find it like i find it
impressive how people
have just like been able to create this
like because it's not even like it's not
even logically laid out people just have
this unwritten understanding that
okay yeah this is but this is part of
the trash taste law and part of the
church
group the only other like group i've
seen this dedicated is like people who
are like into the nasu verse right it's
like
this is like wow just call me out joey
call me out like that
it's the face it's the it's the fate
yeah it's like it's
they're [ __ ] pulling it from like
literally nowhere that has anything to
do with anything being like well i mean
god did say this thing on this like tiny
like youtubers podcast like
six years ago yeah i'm pretty sure this
has a connection
somewhere to one of these episodes right
it's it's weird man it feels like the
first time on
youtube where people like actively care
about what i'm doing
like doesn't that sound strange like
before i just felt like no one gave a
[ __ ] what i was up to right yeah just do
my own thing
yeah now i feel like people actually
actually like watch when i do something
like whoa this is weird well that's the
thing it's like i've i've noticed that
whenever i go into the subreddit it's
like
half of these posts have nothing to do
with the actual trash taste episodes and
it's like
it's either drawn from like someone's
twitter or someone's twitch or
a guest's twitter or a guest twitch yeah
it's like
or like a friend of one of the hosts
yeah
what i'm just gonna call her i mean i
i'm not saying this is a bad thing
i'm just like i just find it really
interesting that yeah became like that
i know what i find really interesting
that people are able to follow along
with this where there's even though
there's like there's no [ __ ] coherent
watch order
you know like we've gone to the point
where you can watch every
episode of trash taste and still not
understand everything going on in the
subreddit right because then you have to
follow our content
and follow other people's content other
people's twitter and i'm just like
god [ __ ] down man respect to you
i'm just so confused i'm on this podcast
and i don't know
i i can't keep up with the [ __ ]
don't know i don't know what's canon and
what's not canon anymore like what is
canon what is not canon
um it's just i i i just view it as
one of the people in like the [ __ ]
law and i'm just like
damn man what is going on i guess i did
say or do that
i don't know everyone should call me a v
tuber now so
that's all they call me now yeah that's
been the that's been the hot meme
we just dated this episode again by just
saying that right now the big hot meme
on the trash there's subreddit is connor
making every youtuber interacts with
into a connoisseur
essentially which is hilarious because
you were the i've seen this [ __ ]
screenshot everywhere whenever someone
mentions that like
you're the youtuber soon now being like
there's one screenshot that just says
i don't understand v2 i i still kind of
don't like
me while every youtuber is like well i
understand
yeah i don't know i i really enjoy
collaborating with youtubers
and and talking to them i think mainly
from the aspect of like
you know i don't particularly care about
the character themselves or who they're
playing
yeah i think she's a content creator
myself i've had it really interesting
what it takes to play a character like
that permanently
yeah and it's normally you know when you
talk to the
vtubers if i talk to them offline you
know you know you normally get some
really interesting uh bits of
information
just about how you know how they like
prepare or how they think about it and i
just find that really fascinating
and then i think you know when you're
collaborating with um
uh v tuber i don't know why i think
there's a really interesting dynamic
that you can work off really well if
it's 1v2
and one like irl person yeah where
although i think a lot of maybe die hard
youtuber fans would think
no never you know i'm sure yeah
yeah i think there is some really
interesting room for like
really fun and and interesting
collaborations that come across because
of the 2d 3d mix well i i completely
agree because
um like i i kind of remember when
ladybird was on like a few
now a few weeks ago i guess um but i
remember like hearing his story and
hearing how he
goes about you know his character and
his stage presence and everything like
that
i was just like yeah i kind of think
youtubers like i said youtubers were
wrestling with waifus and after talking
to ladybird i'm just like
yeah they kind of i i kind of agree with
myself more now
god cognitive dissonance i found
something that proves my point
thus it is correct no i do agree you
know i mean i you know i spoke to
plenty of youtubers and you know you
there's a you hear so many different
reasons is why they became youtubers
like
oh i just wanted easy money or something
oh i really really like this character
i've always or i've
or you know i i can't do anything with
my face i'm too anxious or
yeah everyone has their own reason and
it's really [ __ ] cool to hear about
that and uh get to know the people
behind it sometimes yeah
i i feel though like especially recently
like you know maybe still in japan there
might still be a thing of
oh you know 2d and 3d shouldn't mix you
know like the irl
and uh vtuber should never do stuff
together because it breaks the immersion
but i feel in the west especially
recently i feel that
idea is slowly starting to fade because
especially you know if we look at like v
shojo right like they're doing a lot a
lot more like collaborations with irl
stream
like jana's did that whole thing where
they did a tour of japan
yeah right yeah and that was irl and uh
i think
just yesterday as of us of of this
episode
um anthony padilla did like i spent a
day with v choose yeah yeah
we actually had a they actually had a
clip of trash taste of the cali episode
on
oh really on that on yeah yeah and i
just feel like
at least in the west you know they're
sure there still might be a lot of like
die hard
youtuber fans who don't want that
illusion to be broken or whatever
um but i feel the majority of them are
kind of just like well
i mean let's not kid ourselves right
like these are
also people and you know i think it's
cool to see this like
really weird two different worlds
completely clashing with one another
in a really cool way because like i i
will say like i have been watching
less youtubers as like 2021 has rolled
around
right part of the reason of that is that
anime has gotten really really good
again so i've just had less yeah
but sorry scripted wife who's active
back to the scripted one back to the
scripted ones
um but also it's it's less that i've
just been watching less youtubers but
i've just been watching more
streamers in general now and not even
watching streams but watching like
the stream highlights and the stream
content that's been posted on youtube
um because i feel like there is a
definite difference between
hololive and v shoujo right because i
feel like v shojo
are v tubers who are streamers yeah and
i feel like hololive is
definitely more like treated as idols
yeah i don't know and
it what i what i what i found is that i
kind of more gravitated towards seeing
the uh not uh v tubers as content
creators like
i just i just respect them as content
creators more than anything and
like i you know i i've never understood
idle anime or like the idol kind of
industry itself so that's why i've
gravitated more towards
youtubers who i think i just like beyond
anything are just talented content
creators and yes
and just doing good content and i think
that's might be one of the big reasons
why
nowadays i'm watching a lot of streamers
from niji sanji
because again like it's not so much they
kind of treat their v
tubers again like streamers like actual
content creators because they don't
they're not really seen i'm sure there
are people who view new signs of
youtubers as idols quote unquote but
yeah i feel
just been in like a lot of live streams
of all sorts of different ninja
scientific creators they're definitely a
lot more just like
just people or like streamers and
content creators who are just here to
have
you know just just shoot the [ __ ] and
just happen yeah i mean like
yeah again like i feel there's like a
different type of enjoyment to that
as well as you know how hololive is kind
of seen in that sense and like
i'm not saying one is better than the
other personally but i just think it's
like a really interesting dynamic
because
people just think oh if you're a v tuber
you're immediately like
whole life or you're immediately like
the shojo like you're just kind of
thrown into this like single basket of
you are this type of content creator
with this type of fan base when yeah
in reality it's very very different
depending on how you
i guess treat your character yeah you
know
even in hollow life even even in the
hololive agency itself there are like
a lot of a lot of streamers in hollow
life are doing like very very different
content but i think the difference is
now
that you know 2020 was the year of the v
tuber or or hololive's year right
because it was just like they'll be like
the zodiac exactly the year of the
youtubers
yeah yeah i mean 2020 was the year of
the v2 yeah i don't feel like the hype
is
you know i mean obviously there's the
viewership still there but i think that
the the craze that was there the growth
yeah
it's definitely going to be harder uh to
grow as a youtuber yeah
even in an agency like hololive now
because there's so much competition out
there it's like the gold rush is already
like
yeah the golden age is kind of over
right yeah and i think this year has
really for me
separated like v tubers not just
youtubers but streamers who are doing
like
really really interesting content and
just interesting ideas
versus you know you know a youtuber who
you know
doesn't like doesn't put as much thought
into that content maybe and just
yeah you know um i'm trying to find a
way a nice way to work that but
the good ones from the bad as to
everything no not the good ones from the
bad but just the ones who the stronger
ones
the ones who really view this as like as
as content and just like as an
entertainment platform rather than not
just as like a gimmick right yeah
yeah exactly because i feel like the
gimmick part is over now
the gimmick era is over and if you want
to grow as a youtuber now you
need you need to have solid content
right and i think it's because like
you know the the idea of v tubing as a
gimmick now is just so
just common knowledge now that yeah
whenever a new youtuber comes out
not as many people are like oh my god
did you see
this like it's like a virtual person on
my stream right now like yeah everyone
knows what a feature is now i'm like
so curious about where this is gonna go
because i think this
like i you know we're in a we're in a
good spot right now right i feel like
it's in like
the middle period if you will yeah well
like everything's pretty chill
everything's all good
yeah um i i'm really interested to see
how the community in general will handle
things like
all right what if a youtuber wants to
quit what if avicii wants to be an art
like
show their face and just start streaming
like that yeah
when these stuff because this hasn't
happened yet like can anyone do you know
of any youtubers who have been like yeah
[ __ ] do you choose like big youtubers
they've been like [ __ ] this i'm going to
show my face and do normal streams
probably the one that comes to mind is
kids and i uh the original one
right yeah but that's different that i
feel like i mean she wasn't considered
like a streamer like she wasn't a
youtuber
you're talking about like new jersey i'm
like they're like the v tubers right now
right
you know i mean there's been a lot of
sanji uh v tubers who have quit
for no reason like well i wonder if it's
no reason or
you know ndas have been signed you can't
well no actually there was one
where she openly was like i'm quitting
just because i found something else to
do
like there's nothing like i have no bad
blood or anything and i can say that
contractually
yeah i just want to quit because i have
something new to do and everybody in
that fan base took it
really really well they were like well
it's going to suck that you're going to
go but
at least all your old content is still
here right like good luck bro kind of
thing but yeah
yeah yeah but that's good yeah i mean
obviously at some point i can imagine
that because there's
agencies and agencies aren't always the
best right
there's probably going to be a messy
break up if you will at some point right
oh i mean there has been in the past but
i mean obviously i don't want to get
into that i don't even know about i know
all the messy breakups that have
happened yeah because of agency stuff
but
a lot of that is like it's kind of just
like well i mean
it's an agency we're dealing with and
they're you know they're trying their
best to sweep everything up
i think i don't even want to deal with
that [ __ ] let's not dig that stuff yeah
let's
let's not dig that stuff up it's right
like it's their problem yeah [ __ ] it
you know yeah because like i'm just
interested to see how the
i mean i i guess how the industry grows
right it's so new right is it going to
be vtuber apology videos
if so will that be a deep sigh will they
look into the camera these are the
things i want to know like yeah i feel
like it's like
it's like re-watching youtube like
evolve but like
on like 10 times speed yeah it's just
like it's it's
so it's so new and like nothing's been
defined the rules aren't set in stone
everyone's kind of doing their own thing
and it's in the wild west right now yeah
and it's i i just love watching it and
just hearing about it and just
yeah it's so fascinating for that reason
and you know like i said i don't really
watch youtubers i watch my friends
because i'm like you know gotta
support your friends yeah yeah um and
cause like
one one thing that i always think about
and one reason why i could like never be
a youtube myself is is i think about it
and
like part of part of like what i love
about being a youtuber
and making content where people know who
i am is being able to meet
fans and being able to meet people at
conventions and stuff like that
and i just think like i just think you
know especially with
conventions and the ax stuff and you
know every every public meeting
cancelled
last year and possibly this year as well
yeah i'm sad because
like i don't get to get the what's
what's the word i'm looking for i don't
interaction
i don't get to get the interaction
because what about that at the end of
the day
like there's looking at numbers means
nothing to me right
meeting the people and meeting the fans
a lot of times it resets
like it resets like it reminds me of the
reason why i do this yeah and why i love
doing this right
like months of stress can be like wiped
out by like one week
a weekend of just meeting fans yeah yeah
because like i don't know man it's just
like it's it's so wholesome it's like
it's a rewarding experience that you're
like it's just it's so
unique it gets it gives you something
tangible
or like the work that you've done and i
just think man i can't imagine being a
youtuber a v
tuber and just never being able to meet
fans
like in person right yeah and and just
knowing there's a sony
so many people who like love you and
what you do yeah and love everything
about it yeah i can never see it
there is like weirdly no better feeling
than just like minding your own business
going out and then someone stopping you
on the street being like i [ __ ] love
you yeah exactly and like
look because like because i mean well
that sounds
but i have had fan relationships like
that but like
yeah but like as a youtuber no one knows
what you look like right unless you're
or even that or like even in some
universe where you could meet fans
like they would expect you to be this
character yeah yeah
do they actually like you or do they
like this character
it's it's this it's a weird dynamic that
i can't imagine
myself having well it's like but i guess
we appreciate that right yeah
i you know there's some youtubers
youtubers out there that are probably
like
they the last thing they ever want to do
is meet anyone
right and actually i get you know yeah
yeah and i feel we can say
that you know we might not be able to
experience that and oh it's sad that
they can't experience that because
you know because we've experienced you
know fans coming up to us and liking us
and praising us
for who we are and how we show ourselves
but you know
i mean i don't know there might be some
youtubers out there who have probably
never experienced that right so they
probably don't even
know the joy yeah of that they just
think well
of course the only fan interactions i'm
going to have is people who like my
character
and that's fine [ __ ] 10
you're the same you're the same person
who like plays pokemon is like
they said peepee
no but like you know because i feel if a
v tuber went from
traditional youtubing where they get
that kind of fan experience
to then go on to v tubing and get a
completely different type of fan
experience
then sure you know there might be like
oh [ __ ] well i mean this fan interaction
is cool
but it's not the same kind of you know
gratification i got when it was just me
in front of a camera right yeah but
to a lot of these youtubers they don't
know any better yeah so they're probably
just like well
yeah of course people like me for my
character and they probably don't give a
[ __ ]
you know for me it's i feel it's the
same as you know people going up to
voice actors and actresses
and being like i love you because you
played this character yeah
right i feel it's the exact same thing
it's like well to them that's
they're probably expecting that yeah
it's it's weird because i
i i obviously look at this as a con from
a content creator's perspective
and you know if if i if i did ever get
the chance to give you that
if i did ever get the chance to meet any
youtubers that i really liked i would
like just wanted to say hey love the
[ __ ] content you're doing
um i also find it really fascinating the
kind of like mindset you have to be
to be this kind of content creator right
because it's such a different field from
what we're doing
and i don't know it just it just it's
just really interesting to me yeah
and just this is this what it feels like
when like a parent
is like it's like i don't get this whole
youtubing thing but it must be very
difficult
i could never see myself doing it no i
mean that's why i really
uh that's why i really uh respect
streamers because they do something that
i find
[ __ ] difficult to do like i i don't
know how and i'm sure it's vice versa
for the streamer
yeah i don't know i don't know how you
go home and stream sometimes come on i'm
just like
i go home i'm done i am i sleep yeah
i don't know how you get home and sleep
look at look at you you disgusting i
don't know
i just i like it it's fun i don't know i
like talking yeah it's it seems fun it
seems like the streaming the streaming
sphere right now seems like it's just
fun
it just seems like it's you you get more
chances to really collaborate and make
friends as well which is one thing i'm
really jealous about
i don't know if it's because i'm paying
more attention to streaming it just
seems like it's in a really good place
right now
i think it is it's funny because i think
streaming is in a really good place i
think twitch
is like it's it that we've complained
about youtube
my god twitch as a platform jesus christ
yeah it is almost just from how i see it
it
seems like it's almost [ __ ]
impossible to grow on twitch as like
someone who's coming from nothing yeah i
was wait do you guys know why are all
the youtubers on youtube why is it
mostly uh at least japanese ones why are
they on youtube because
youtube i feel oh i mean this is just my
guess but i feel it's because
youtube to a japanese audience is a lot
more well known than twitches
i feel twitch i mean not to say that
there aren't massive japanese streams on
twitch there are
and yeah some of them pull insane
[ __ ] numbers but i feel it's just
two completely different worlds like
i know this is just my guess but i feel
for a regular japanese
viewer of content online you
stick only to one website and that's it
yeah whereas like
you know i feel it's like if you're a
youtube watcher you are exclusively a
youtube watcher if you're a twitch
watcher you're a twitch watcher if
you're a nico nico watcher
you're only on nico nico whereas i feel
that same mentality doesn't work for
a western viewer right like western view
will be like well yeah i'm going to
watch some content on youtube i get
where the content is
but yeah but like i can also go on to
twitch if i want to yeah i guess so
because maybe yeah i mean for me i'd
hardly watch any twitch
at all on the twitch platform but i
think what's becoming more common now is
like
twitch and youtube are becoming more and
more intertwined
where like a lot of some of the most
popular content and some of the most
original content as well right now has
been
twitch highlights yeah and that's why
i've grown way more of an appreciation
for twitch like i i still
spend very little time on the platform
as a as a consumer but i
end up consuming a lot of twitch content
on youtube which is why i think like one
of my favorite content creators right
now it's probably ludwig
where he's just doing like the subathon
that he's doing right now is
insane [ __ ] insane definitely over by
now yeah yeah
definitely hopefully it's over by now oh
my god
i was like are you gonna like die on
camera like yeah is that when the
subathon hints
sleeping on camera is like one of the
most bizarre things for me to
like think about doing let's just want
to do we want to explain
what who ludwig is yes sir used to be uh
very big in the smash community um then
moved to streaming and just became like
an instant hit
streaming he's very funny uh very
naturally charismatic he's he's just a
natural-born entertainer
yeah yeah and he did a thing where every
sub
it adds 10 seconds i believe something
like that so every time someone
subscribes to his twitch channel 10
seconds get added and it went up to like
you know 70 hours so so the big
difference is that he made
normally in a subathon you you cap the
number of hours
that you can possibly stream for a time
he made the stream
stream uncapped and i think right now
he's been streaming for over a week
continuously it's like two weeks i think
so is it two weeks yeah yeah and then he
just sleeps on stream and that's
something to me i'm like dude what if i
just like i like
say things in my sleep
i don't know what you say just like i
don't want to know
i don't say anything bad but what if
it's the one day where i say something
you know that gta clip all the mods of
it where you know they say the thing
about you know what if you go to bed and
then you just say it out loud when
you're sleeping can you be canceled for
being racist in your sleep
i don't know that's that's
okay okay if so if that actually
happened
would you be cancelled if someone said
you know they're thinking in their sleep
it depends if you're a youtuber or not
youtubers are just like that word is
just like free games yeah
exactly everyone every youtuber has that
pass for some reason especially if
they're japanese but
what if you're a white guy ludwig
ludwig's sleeping and then he sleeps
sleep talking and he says that you know
do you get canceled god there's a part
of me that says
that's ridiculous of course not and then
another part of me is like no he would
definitely get canceled
i'm i'm gonna be canceled for your
dreams
that's like some george orwell [ __ ] dude
like do you have control over you what
does this say about you
if you say a racist call on your dream
police if you say a racist thing in your
dream
are you racist
like the plot of inception everyone
instead of like putting in an idea you
just go in the dream just to cancel them
in the dream they'll be like i'll be
like two camps they'll be like the camp
that believes like you know okay well he
just said in the scene there'll be
another
thing like i bet he's secretly awake and
said because he's racist
nobody says that in this nobody unless
he's awake
she's awake and racist this is a really
weird tangent i just thought like
you know i think it's a very valid
thought experiment though like it's a
very valuable i wouldn't
like to all respect how the [ __ ] was
that the first thing you thought
when you saw someone sleeping on the
stream my
what i see when i see sleeping through
stream as a content creator i just think
like
everything could go wrong yeah what if i
[ __ ] myself in my sleep
everything can be taken out of context
what if i do a rip an absolute
massive fart like the wettest thing just
like any of the stuff that like could
reasonably happen in sleep that is
totally normal
not being racist in your sleep i don't
know if that's normal probably probably
isn't
like you know you know and like he takes
his shirt off
when he's uh when he was sleeping right
and you know what if you just like
because you know sometimes
you [ __ ] throw the sheets off
somewhere you're sleeping yeah i wonder
oh yeah you sleep naked as well don't
you well i also
i mean what if i just like pop a nut on
the stream right like
if you get you know you're lying down
you've got a morning wood big big boner
yeah
right on stream 4k like you get banned
for that like there's just
i'm just literally the stuff that you
would never ever think would ever happen
normally when you're sleeping right
you suddenly become like this is my
number one worry now honestly
it is valid it is yeah i mean there's a
lot of things you don't you can't
control it
you know yeah there's a lot of things
because with youtube we can we could
easily edit stuff out if we said
something you know but i just want to
say if i
if i shat myself i would own it by the
way
i would yeah yeah yeah i would never i
mean like
i feel like the possibly like the worst
thing that could happen on stream when
you're sleeping is that you just utter a
racist word
i'm just thinking yeah would you rather
would you rather usher a racist word
asleep or [ __ ] yourself i'd rather [ __ ]
myself
shake yourself on stream that's great
content you're not going to get canceled
if anything you will be immortalized on
the internet as the one dude think about
the
amount of [ __ ] himself think about the
amount of subs you'd get for [ __ ]
yourselves on stream
i could just see it you know you say
something racist you end up on fox being
like
liberals are trying to cancel this man
for being racist in his sleep
i'm just imagining what if like a
youtuber [ __ ] themselves on the stream
can you imagine the super chat for that
no it would be like i'm weirdly
thanks for that i needed that
um how do we have we've gone on this a
really weird time
about the sub phone i mean um yeah i i
mean i'm like
talking about watching yeah i was
talking about like watching him sleep
um and just like the chat going crazy
and stuff like that i i watch it and i'm
like
weirdly engrossed not because he's
sleeping just because of like the
reaction itself
like how active this chat is right and
i'm just like
man this is this is literally just the
truman show we are we are watching the
truman show happen to watch
but he can't leave his room at least in
the truman show you could walk around
yeah yeah yeah that's true but i mean
this is
this is kind of like the closest we've
had to the truman show and it's it would
drive me into this
it's a [ __ ] black mirror episode it
is [ __ ] i mean
it's fascinating yeah but it's also like
i just find it really weird that
i i don't know what the mentality of
people is where like
you watch this dude sleeping on stream
and then you think to yourself
i'mma drop a hundred subs while he's
asleep
so yeah cause like normally you know i'd
like to think if i dropped 100 subs i
would want him to be like
yo thanks for the 100 like at least a
tiny bit of recognition
from the person who i'm subbing it to
right yeah yeah but it's just like
he's not going to see this at all i'm
gonna just drop 500 bucks just like that
just because i can it's like i don't
know i don't know what the mentality of
it is because like i've given
i don't think anyone does at this point
right because like i've gifted subs
before on stream
right on like other people's chats or
whatever but like
you know dropping a hundred subs on a
dude who's [ __ ] asleep
it's like what do you like what goes
through your head to be like yeah i'm
gonna do that i mean i i think it's just
being part of like this experience right
yeah cause i i feel like this is
you you feel like the the thing about
twitch that you know
i kind of understand is like you do feel
like you're being a part of something
bigger than yourself
right and i feel like especially like
like obviously
he didn't he didn't think he would be
this successful that it was a [ __ ]
genius move
absolutely i was like one day and he
made like 150
000 or something so even even just i
know
he doesn't seem like the kind of guy who
gives a [ __ ] about the money yeah yeah
yeah
but i mean yeah
yeah but but there's also a part of me
where it's like
i just threw away my humanity for 150
thousand dollars right it's like hey
[ __ ] sign me the [ __ ] up
are you kidding me film every part of my
life for a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars
i will [ __ ] myself for a hundred and
fifty thousand dollars i will poop
myself
on stream for a hundred thousand
billionaires trash taste [ __ ]
any billionaires want to fund this the
next trash today's livestream look out
for one of us [ __ ] fighting live on
twitch
jesus christ i just thought of like the
most cursed content i can think of
what you just love people in the room
and just see who shits themselves first
you say they can't go to the toilet
that's that's the beast
right themselves wins a million dollars
it's like survivor just with jimmy i
just gave you a fantastic idea bro
you don't have to give me credit for
that
oh my god where do we go from here
i don't know like i don't know i just
find it i just find it fascinating where
it's like you know
you see a content creator like ludwig on
twitch where he's just [ __ ]
you know doing something that is not
exactly the most
unique thing but it's also that one
thing where it's like well i wouldn't
[ __ ] do it so obviously no one's
gonna do it yeah right
but i'm just like when it gets to this
point of like yeah i've been streaming
for two weeks straight like
can it go up from there like what what
is what's gonna be the next thing
because everyone's gonna be waiting for
the next subathon right yeah yeah i'm
just kidding
and it's just gonna be even longer right
yeah no please no no
and like let's like i don't think
there'll be a subathon that'll be as
popular as this because he was the first
one who did it and unless he does it
again
i mean even if he does it again i feel
like the hype wouldn't be
as big because it's it's unless no i i
don't know i'm
you know listen like unless it
prematurely fizzles out
yeah right where it's like i don't know
i don't even know when this one's gonna
end yet
right so who who the [ __ ] knows i mean
it's it's kind of like
drama twitch plays pokemon oh yeah yeah
i was actually about to say right yeah
because like
the last time i saw this phenomenon was
during twitch plays
yeah that's that's the kind of [ __ ] i'm
gonna be telling my kids about right
like honestly i enjoyed the twitch plays
pokemon experience so [ __ ] high
sun remember that time when twitch
played pokemon no doubt but like
but like the one week thing is like it's
like twitch plays pokemon but instead of
an algorithm that's just reading the
chat it's literally just a dude
reading everything in the chat being
like okay left down
up so so to explain twitch plays pokemon
like
this was how many years ago now oh
six years ago where someone made like
someone
like an australian dude actually i was
in australia so basically someone made
um a program that would allow the twitch
chat
to play a full game of pokemon right so
i think it was pokemon red
yes that was played and basically the
chat could put in their inputs
and whatever yeah and whatever inputs
were put in would be inputted into this
emulator
that would be played live in front of
you so if you typed in left in chat and
then yeah
entered it then the program would in
order go left yeah but
the trick is there was literally what
like
fifty thousand hundred thousand plus
people yeah watching this watching and
chatting
and chatting so it's like it's like
giving the game boy to a hundred
thousand people at once
being like finish this game yeah and
it's one of the few times where the word
social experiment
actually meant social experiments right
it reminds me of it
i saw a clip the other day i was like if
the moon landing happened with twitch
chat
and then they were like literally just
put like an overlay it's like pog
it's such a good video and i imagine how
much more hype would the moon landing be
with a bunch of pogba oh dude i would
absolutely be popular
this video is sponsored by liquid iv
when you push your body hard or just
feel run down it's extremely important
to stay hydrated making hydration a
priority
helps us feel healthier on a day to day
basis with one stick of liquid iv in 16
ounces of water you get
two to three times the amount of
hydration as plain water honestly
every time i'm hungover now i take one
of these bad boys i honestly feel a lot
better well yeah it's like
doing like water times three right
it does help actually means a side wait
what flavors do we have gone well today
with us we have
lemon lime and strawberry which this one
on hangovers they taste amazing
they get dehydrated this is what you
need liquid iv is so effective
because of their cellular transport
technology i am not qualified to know
what that means
but i feel very refreshed and hydrated
after i have a stick so you can grab
your liquid iv
in bulk nationwide at costco or you can
get 25
off when you go to liquidive.com and use
code trash taste
at checkout that's 25 off anything you
order
when you get better hydration today
using promo code trash taste at
liquidive.com
remember bros keep yourself hydrated
back to the episode
i would love to see sporting events with
twitch chat like can you imagine how fun
the olympics would have been
if it was streamed on twitch well it's
funny if you say that because i recently
someone in my twitch chat notified me of
this twitch channel that streams the
sumo
on twitch and okay dead ass there are
people every time one of them wins
there is dead ass just a stream of pog
that happens and i'm just like
this is weird that people are pogging a
sumo wrestler i'll be like [ __ ]
professional backseat is coming out
being like you know i sumo wrestle for
10 years
you know this technique's pretty [ __ ]
lackluster here's how i would have
optimized that
obviously this is just sloppy behavior
dude i saw a clip that popped up on my
youtube as well
and it was like twitch chat goes crazy
about car stopping
what and it was just like a camera
that's watching a street with a stop
sign
yeah and like a security camera footage
yeah yeah
and they're just streaming it and you
see twitch chat in the corner and no one
stops the stop sign
but then one car stops at the stop sign
and twitch checker is [ __ ] crazy
i'm just like who's watching this why is
there hundreds of people watching this
going crazy that's really funny i i feel
like it's the equivalent of
do you remember the dvd logo
when the dvd thing hits the corner
twitch the amount of pogs in chat now
the amount of pogs in chat
every time it's so close it's like oh
monkeys
but not like yeah going back to twitch
plays pokemon like part of
part of the amazing experience of that
was being like being part of something
bigger and
i just i just loved the law that
that came out twitch plays pokemon right
you you weren't on the subreddit and
everything like that i wasn't on the
subway
okay so there's like factions forming
against each other you know and stuff
like that yeah yeah yeah so
what happened is you know you it was a
random game played by twitch chat or not
randomly it was like
it was like a game played by a lot of
people and a lot of random things
happened yeah and
out of this randomness like the
community just created a kind of
storyline and they created a narrative
out of the chaos that was happening
right yes they did and so
we're going full circle now because an
entire law was created out of the chaos
and the randomness that was happening on
twitch plays pokemon right right and
and so part like people got invested
in this narrative people got super super
[ __ ] invested in this law
god um the helix fossil and the helix
fossil right
oh i mean yeah i know that's where like
the whole like lord helix meme came from
yeah but like that's that's the extent
yeah i know it was like you know
they wanted more some people like half
people wanted more order and half people
wanted the chaos
yeah and it was just like arguing and
stuff and it was quite interesting yeah
the only thing i remember from
twitch plays pokemon is well they
eventually finished it
uh i think they released their starter
within like the first
i think like hour or something yeah yeah
yeah yeah we're trying to sabotage yeah
people are trying to
start and then obviously the whole world
helix thing
but other than that like i don't know
you know at first when i heard about it
i was like oh i have to [ __ ]
go on to this and yeah participate in
subway right like i feel like i gotta be
part of this history
yeah the moment i went in and the the
chat is moving
so [ __ ] fast where it just looks like
a blur i'm like i remember i typed it
never mind i'm good
i typed in the command and i was like
wow i didn't see it yeah exactly
i was trying to catch it being like well
i didn't see it [ __ ] it whatever
no because like i mean there was like so
many epic moments created out of the
most mundane
situations like i remember there was
this one ledge
that took like [ __ ] eight hours to
cross something like that
and it was like the most epic ledge
i think i watched that collectively for
like three hours at least on my own time
and you know we we talk about what is
the mentality of people watching someone
sleeping and i'm just like wait a minute
i just watched three hours of of this
video game character trying to cross the
[ __ ] ledge i i haven't
i have i i can't act like i'm better
than anyone else because i [ __ ] did
that as well oh god
we need like a a category of competitive
gaming where it's like a team does like
everyone gets one button
like dark souls but everyone gets one
button each well actually one of my
friends
uh they're like a couple streamer and
they do
split control secure so one of them is
on the mouse and the other
is on the keyboard and they beat the
whole game on split controls i'm just
like
this is the type of [ __ ] that's like why
why would you subject yourself to this
pain i can i could barely play secure
with both of my own hands yeah yeah let
alone having the [ __ ] curry and also
like
they managed to beat the whole game
without getting mad at one another i'm
like that's not how it works
that's scripted yeah scripted fake
what's wrong with you
what's wrong with you two have you seen
that one twitch streamer who like plays
league of legends with the most random
inputs uh is it ross
boone's i don't know his name i don't i
don't remember but i remember like
bananas yeah like
we played league of legends using
bananas as inputs
yeah because i think it's not that
difficult because you just need
something that because there's only like
like really like four major yeah yeah so
you just need to
have something that takes four inputs
you could literally do that with
anything right right right
but i mean that that's that's why i
think i've been watching more stream
content
right now because i think to me as a
youtube creator you know we
we watch a lot of youtube and i feel
like we can definitely see
the formula of good content on youtube
and
it's rare nowadays that i look at a
youtube video and i'm like
well that is uh that is you're doing
something really original right now
because because i mean you know you know
we had a few years ago where missed the
beast completely revolutionized the
platform
yeah and now it just feels like he's the
one coming up with the original ideas
you know
mr beast like head and shoulders above
the rest yeah and i feel like
he's someone who is one was someone who
understood the platform
and two now has the resources to do the
craziest ideas that literally no one
else no one else can think of doing
like who the [ __ ] just makes a [ __ ]
burger chain for content
right like who else can do that well
who else can [ __ ] ask when i saw that
video myself feed i was like
it's a rap guy it's like that like he
just won the game
yeah like crazy yeah like you know
there's
you know not to say there's people not
doing good content on youtube but the
amount of
original ideas you can put on youtube i
feel like there's a lot less now because
one someone with bigger resources and
is like probably smarter than you is
probably doing it and two um i feel like
a lot of the original content i see is
now on twitch
and i i don't know if that's just
because i'm not being recommended the
right videos on youtube
yeah i know i definitely do just think
that right now we're kind of in like a
golden age of like
twitch creativity like there was just so
many ideas that people
thought would be like either too much
effort or wouldn't you know
reap the benefits of doing it live yeah
because there was just so much room for
error but now people
have gone to the point and there's
enough people i feel now on twitch
that there's at least one person who's
gonna be like this might be risky
for a lot of different reasons but i'm
gonna just try it and see if it lands
and a lot of the times it does land in
ways that no one was really expecting me
like oh you can do that on twitch
yeah and it'd be really [ __ ]
successful well then i'm gonna try and
do it too and it's just like
i don't know i feel it's just like
feeding the creativity
to more and more streamers being like oh
you know i feel like we're past that
point of just get in front of a camera
and just start playing a game
yeah we're way past that i don't know if
you were ever like
watching twitch and this is the thing
that like marbles was like a huge thing
at one point
what yeah like watching a bunch of
marbles go down a course and like seeing
which one won
like rude goldberg machines or like just
like it was like
there's like simulations of like marbles
and people would like
bet on the marbles like i think ludwig
did this as well oh i think tecton did
it as well
yeah you can assign things like the
balls yeah just let all these balls go
down whichever one wins you like you
know that kind of like salty bets
i don't know what that is salty bets is
i i'm not i'm 100 sure
about this but i believe someone made it
like a program
right where it's they pitted two
characters
against each other in a fighting game
i'm not sure what the fighting game was
i know what's wrong about this because
they have like [ __ ] sonic going
against like chun li
yeah yeah yeah i know yeah um no it's
not like and people would be betting on
the winner even though
it was a completely you know ai battle
right no it was just like the streamer
i can't remember exactly because i never
watched it fully speaking i think it's
like they're like reacting to like these
marbles
in virtual like games going down it was
really bizarre
it's like horseradish betting but like i
find that like stuff like that does well
on twitch chat when you're overreacting
well i mean that's the whole reason why
at one point or i mean i would argue
still to this day
people love watching people do gotcha on
stream right because it's like
people losing their [ __ ] to pngs it's
like well of course i'm gonna watch this
this is ridiculous
i'm gonna watch it and play a part i
play and play a part i can say that
because i've done gotcha on stream
and i have overreacted and it's been
[ __ ] amazing oh my god i got
something
i got the waifu you know it's like it's
the same it's the same philosophy right
bro it's just a png bro it's just a png
this is png man but then the amount of
pogs i'm seeing in the chat
is like saying otherwise it's not
because yeah i i guess to me
the one thing you get away you can do on
twitch or live streaming
that you can't do with youtube content
is just really have this community
aspect right
and it's something that i feel is
getting more and more
like it's before it was seen as like
youtube comments or just that the thing
that comes
after the content it's the reaction to
the content but now like
the ca the comments itself and the
reaction to the to the content that's
being made is also
part of the content itself and that's
what i what i see
being like kind of like the future and
the future of online content and how
it's kind of evolving right now and this
at least that is
that's that's how i see it right because
there's
like even even with like twitch streams
that have been put on youtube
you know i feel like half the fun is
lost if they don't have the twitch chat
on the content itself yeah you miss a
lot of the context itself and if it's
just like a stream highlights
uh without the twitch shot itself i i
feel like you're missing
half of the content itself no i i
absolutely agree like i feel a lot of it
gets taken out of context where like
if you don't see the reaction it doesn't
seem as
epic as it actually is like it's still
epic
yeah but when you see a twitch chat on
the screen
going [ __ ] crazy you're like oh this
is really epic
okay this is an epic gamer moment right
now i don't know if it's like placebo or
whatever but it's like the moment you
see a hyped twitch chat
suddenly you're like well i have to get
hyped too [ __ ] because when you're
watching on mobile
who the [ __ ] has the chat open on the
site because it like squishes down
yeah yeah yeah it's like i'm not gonna
[ __ ] watch this [ __ ] with the channel
just like put it just put it on the
stream and then that way it's the best
viewing experience as well yeah
yeah i mean like what i mean i don't
watch twitch
on the phone most of the time um i mean
you know sometimes i want to watch
twitch and um
i'll watch it every now and then like if
i'm on the train somewhere you know it's
just seeing like oh someone's streaming
whatever yeah i guess do you guys watch
a lot of like
twitch and live streaming yourself or do
you watch the highlights
i mostly just like jump into like one of
my friends streams if they're streaming
just say hi
yeah i normally watch my mates streaming
yeah so what are you up to huh yeah
i literally used it as an excuse to just
catch up with my friends
like i could like message you on twitter
dms or whatever but like
you're here right now you're gonna
respond to me i do watch highlights too
um
just not as often uh i prefer i still
prefer normal youtube videos on youtube
right right right um and yeah i mean i
don't i mean there's so much [ __ ] i got
to watch as well like anime and i i love
watching
anime what is that who's watching it oh
right you don't know her
but yeah you know when i want to keep
doing all the things i like so it's
difficult to keep up with everything
yeah it's kind of like there's just so
much content that i want to watch now
and there's not enough time anymore
like yeah tell me about it literally
literally literally can't get more first
world problem than that
right there's just too much to do
there's too much content man life sucks
in a good way
yeah in a good way yeah exactly but
i mean like did you okay here's a
question for you guys do you like when
you watch youtube and
twitch you feel like it's part of your
job
to watch it or just no no i don't i i
still feel like i'm
i'm you know back in 2013 watching my
favorite content creators
well then the changes now is that you
know oh [ __ ] they follow me maybe on
twitter maybe they probably don't but
maybe
i don't know like in a way to me it kind
of
it's like half off for me because it's
like you know there are some
videos that just pop up in my
recommended where i'm just like this is
so
little to do with what i do for a job
yeah that it just becomes entertainment
yeah but then there are parts of me
which are like i could like say watch a
a video idea or a video that has this
particular idea that
i had no idea existed yeah and there's
i'd be lying if i said there wasn't a
part of me
that thinks oh i wonder if i can use
this
idea that this video is using and kind
of spin it in a way for my own content
yeah right it's like
it um it's it's not so much like i'm
going out onto youtube
just trying to find the next idea or
whatever but sometimes there are some
videos where it's just like
i could do that but in like a kind of
fun and unique way for myself right yeah
because
i do that as well where i watch youtube
i watch twitch i'm constantly i'm
constantly looking for ways to
improve my own content yeah and seeing
seeing some things that i can maybe like
like not one-on-one ripping someone off
but like taking taking an aspect and
think being like
i can put my own spin on that right like
you know there have been moments where
i've made entire videos
based off ideas from like three or four
completely unrelated videos and
just kind of being like i'll take you
know this idea from this video and this
idea from this completely separate video
yeah
and what do you know i've come up with
something kind of cool and unique that i
can work off of as well which is
kind of unique and interesting to my
audience yeah cause i i think there's
like it's really looked down upon um
like i don't know if it's just the
creator community or even like when
whenever
with the audience as well whenever you
see something that kind of resembles
someone else you're just like oh you're
just ripping off x or you're just
ripping off why
whereas like i don't know like to me
like artists like musicians
and like you know movie makers they
they're they're like really open
about their influences yeah like like
some of them were the influences on
their sleeves yeah people are just like
cool yeah i i don't know why it's it's
looked down upon in the youtube space
because everyone's exactly the same
everyone's been influenced by someone
else
on the platform and it's really like the
rarer thing is finding someone who's
completely [ __ ] original right and
like even to me some of the biggest
content creators where i
in my mind they were just like um they
they did something completely
like completely original content like
for example like nakey jakey
or he's doing something very very
different from what other people are
doing even he says
oh yeah i'm kind of just like jontron on
a green screen and uh
i think yeah i think he's just said i'm
just i'm just the shittier jontron on an
exercise yeah yeah yeah
i said in a video and i'm like i mean
you know
you obviously like it's so obvious you
were influenced by jontron but it
doesn't
matter because you're putting your own
spin on it in a unique way you're
putting your own personality on it where
now this
supposed thing you ripped off has just
become you
yeah yeah right i mean you know i i
already give a [ __ ] if someone does
one of my video ideas no um i i you know
that you can 100
just take it um yeah you know if you're
gonna 100
take the idea it would be nice to be
like oh yeah i got this idea from this
person
right yeah uh because if i if i
blatantly copy a video i'll just be like
oh yeah
yeah i mean like who was that person who
just blatantly copied missed the beast
for the longest time
i mean like on that level it's so
obvious that it's just kind of like a
kind of like a one-to-one call thumbnail
title it's a little much because you
might be [ __ ] with things there but
like yeah taking the video idea is like
like whatever i mean right i mean i've
seen you know a bunch of youtubers who
have done
videos that you know i have come up with
or i was known for
and but i've been okay with it because
they've put their own spin on it where
it's just kind of become like well i
know where you got influence from but
yeah this has just become your video now
so
i'm [ __ ] okay with it yeah yeah if it
was like one for one like
reaping my like using the same type of
thumbnail using the same type of title
and then the content is almost one for
one and then you don't mention the
person you got it from then yeah i'll be
like well
that's a little bit shitty isn't it like
yeah yeah because like i one one of like
one of the biggest questions i get asked
is like how how do i go about like a new
content creator is just like
how do i go about making content how do
i go about
making original ideas and finding my own
style and like i always say
you know what stop i don't see any
problem with just
start you know starting by copying some
of your favorite creators
right because you will find your own
style
the more you do your own content right
but it's not something that you
immediately like it's not something that
you immediately figure out and
even like some people do but those are
the rare
rare people yeah those are like the true
geniuses yeah it's like not everyone on
youtube is a genius
and i i think it should be fine for
creators in our fields just to like wear
their influences on their sleeves and
just be open about it
like not completely copying but like
every like you know everyone has their
influences and
everyone continues to evolve from
different people they see on the
platform at least that's how it is with
me
and i think it should be fine you know i
i i think everyone's being influenced
with each other because everyone
yeah i don't know a single youtuber who
doesn't watch youtube
exactly like i mean you know that's the
reason why we're here yeah i mean
you know like i always get reminded of
that uh picasso quote which is like
good artist copy great artist steel
right and like a lot of people
like kind of take that quote completely
out of context thinking like well then
i'll just [ __ ] steal the thing but
like
yeah i actually read up on why he said
that and what he meant by that which is
a great artist steals in the sense that
they take an
influence and they turn it into
something of their own yeah yeah and i
feel that's very valid to
any creative field whether that be an
artist or a movie producer or a youtuber
right where it's like
you can get influenced by other people
but
it's you have to do it to the point
where you put your own thing on it where
it becomes your own thing
yeah right and that's really hard to do
and you know great artists steal good
artist copy you know yeah
youtubers who just copy an idea but
don't do anything creative
with it are the ones that are just like
well you're a [ __ ] copycat
aren't you i i i think one oh did i say
i i never really thought about it much i
was just
i just watched youtube i made my videos
we're getting awfully philosophical
i'm just sitting on my i make [ __ ]
stupid videos it's kind of how like i
view it i'm just like
i'll just keep loading the same [ __ ] i
mean yeah i'm like that too but you know
i'd be lying if i said there wasn't a
part of me that did think about that
being like oh god
i mean this is a cool idea and i want to
you know incorporate and do it because
it just seems like something fun to do
but yeah you know i i i sometimes get
worried being like
are people going to come out and be like
how dare you steal this
excellent idea right like i think about
stuff like that and then i just
also remember like some of the most
popular videos are like pee pee poo poo
stinky
and like that shouting sound effect so
like the moment i try and get all like
deep about i'm like i don't think it's
that deep i think it's
people uploading stuff that makes some
he he xd yeah yeah
i don't [ __ ] know i mean i i i do
think you register it
at least unconsciously i definitely do
yeah because i
i feel like you know when people ask how
do you like
what does it take to become a successful
youtuber a lot of things that are well
the one thing a lot of
people think a lot of like the one thing
that a lot of people don't mention
is that step one i feel like it's to
watch a lot of youtube
well yeah of course like no because i
mean i mean you
say of course but i know people who
don't watch too much youtubers or
if i'm just like name 10 to like name 10
to 20 years
because you're watching they see youtube
on the news they're like oh i want to be
a youtuber
yeah yeah yeah and i i feel like not a
lot of people talk about
a lot of youtubers i know they watch a
[ __ ] ton of youtube right
it feels like there's so many subtle
things that you can't really explain to
someone
unless they just understand the platform
because they watch a [ __ ] ton of youtube
and it's not just
watching a [ __ ] on a youtubers it's
watching a [ __ ] ton of different
youtubers yeah yeah exactly
it's like i could be like name 10 you
know youtubers and if all of them are
the same type of
content then it's like well you
understand that type of content
yeah everything else is just a complete
blank to you right yeah you're probably
not going to go
very far because that would be just be
recycling the same content from those 10
youtubers yeah
or oh it's just like watching youtubers
who are popular like
five years ago right i still watch ray
william johnson every day
i strive
and yeah i i just i just think you know
the the idea
of like yes i would like to become a
youtuber because they are successful now
and you know they make lots of money for
an easy job
yeah yeah and i i feel like step one
before you even consider
becoming a youtuber or a streamer is
just to watch
a [ __ ] ton of things on that no no no
step one is delete your twitter history
you don't want to get canceled it's
pretty good yeah get rid of that
privatization
step two is watching privatize your
facebook delete your twitter
yeah because i i mean that's how i feel
about like instagram and tick tock
because i don't use those platforms and
i'm not going to try to
grow on those platforms because i feel
like you don't use it right because the
first step is i don't understand it so
it's kind of like to me it's just like
that
hello fellow instagrammers kind of thing
if i try to like you just turn into one
of those corporate brands
yeah yeah it's like yes we understand
you there's more picture of my food
that's what you all like right
why aren't you liking it yeah
i mean is there anything else you guys
want to talk about i don't know man
youtube can be deep but it can also be
poo poo pee pee stinky and that's i
think that's what i've gotten out of
today's episode
what i've gotten out of today's episode
is that i don't
understand streaming content sometimes
and that's why i watch it
yeah exactly right like that you know i
feel a lot of the reasons why people
watch a lot of youtube and you know
twitch streaming and stuff like that
first you know if for people who want to
get into it's because they want to
understand it right because they want to
grow greater appreciation towards i mean
that's why i watch it
it just [ __ ] fascinates me man oh
dude twitch twitch is fascinating to me
now and
that's why that's why it's probably the
content that i'm watching the most right
now yeah
um i don't know until until i understand
it fully i'm i'm gonna keep watching it
i guess
you get addicted go on to everything
that you do
you do you you do you do tend to be like
i like this one thing now
i'm going to like it till the end of
time will just come back and be like
guys
you won't believe it i've just
discovered this thing called mahjong
and me and the boys at the magi have
been talking about all the different
strats and i've been watching this photo
and i don't like it
we've watched i've watched the movies
with the boys you know it's just like
all right can't calm down
and don't forget about measuring the
week next yeah exactly that's pretty
much me
like i i find i'm the kind of guy who's
who finds it really easy just to fall
into this one random rabbit hole
and then i reach the bottom of that
rabbit hole and i'm just like okay time
to find something new
literally the the toy story meme of like
i'm done with you
yeah i don't i don't want to play with
you anymore i don't know yeah that's
that's that's me in a nutshell and the
thing is i'm so easy i'm so easily
influenced all it takes is just
one random youtube recommendation or one
thing popping up on my twitter to be
like
i find this thing that this this this
peaks my curiosity let me look into this
and like a week later i'm just like guys
i have just consumed a week's worth of
content on horse riding
like well no your thing right now is
[ __ ] chug jug
that's what that [ __ ] is and i'm just
like dude i'm just thinking to myself
like i'll just let him talk because by
next week he'll be talking about
something else
he'll be done with this one rather
shallow rabbit hole he'll get over it
he'll get over it
just just see me in a week guys i've
become a fortnight gamer
i've become i'm i'm going to be a pro
for like 49
but you know what i won't get over our
patrons it's true they're wonderful like
this guy right here
i absolutely love this guy this is a
rabbit hole i will never get out yes
please feel free to fall down the trash
taste rabbit hole there is definitely a
trash tank oh absolutely and if you want
to support the show make sure to go over
to patreon.comtaste
also follow us on twitter uh fall down
the trash taste rabbit hole on our
subreddit
and if you hate our faces listen to us
on spotify yes let's see how deep we can
make this rabbit hole go
i just want this like the law on the
trashy subreddit to just get
absolutely [ __ ] out of control where
it's like they're just throwing in big
youtubers like
doing [ __ ] now it's like he's felix said
the word trash
we have to add that to the wall this
guy's got nothing to do with anything
exactly we we always want to we just
want to like
expand this universe as far as it will
go i'm just i'm just gonna
i just want to get to a point where the
trash taste law competes with fate law
trash taste cinematic universe
ttcu oh my god thank you thank you for
joining me today jerry
yeah thank you thank you for joining me
connor i've had like three hours of
sleep today i'm ready to die
i feel like you'll like that every week
yeah no this week was exceptional i was
great and then the last half hour i was
like whoa
i'm tired yeah i noticed i looked over
and i'm like you're gonna add to this
conversation
sometimes i'll just look to see if
connor wants to add something and he's
just like i am having trouble forming
words yes
that's the first hour and a half today
i'm like i feel gucci and then the last
half hour hit me like last half hour
aol loading side anyways guys hopefully
you enjoyed and we'll see you guys next
week bye
[Music]
you